good evening everyone my name is Ian
Brown I'm a junior here at Hillsdale
College I'm from Omaha Nebraska and I'm
a history major Spanish minor here thank
you
either way it's my honor this evening to
introduce mr. Fergus M boorda Wieck he
is actually a journalist and a historian
he earns degrees from the City College
of New York and Columbia University he
has served as chairman of the awards
committee for the Frederick Douglass
book prize excuse me
given by the guild erm excuse me the
Gilder Lehrman Center for the Study of
slavery and abolition at Yale University
he has written for numerous publications
including the New York Times The Wall
Street Journal Smithsonian American
heritage Harper's and Reader's Digest
he's the author of several books
including Washington the making of the
American capital America's great debate
Henry Clay Steven a Douglas and the
compromise that preserved the Union and
the first Congress how James Madison
George Washington and a group of
extraordinary men invented the
government it's my pleasure to introduce
mr. Fergus bored awake
[Applause]
good evening everybody I assume you can
hear me clearly good first let me say
it's a great pleasure to be here I've
known about this institution for many
years and it was a I was thrilled to be
invited to come here and and speak to
you and also to finally get a look at
this part of Michigan because in fact
without having been here I wrote a bit
about it in an earlier book that was a
history of the Underground Railroad
which as some of you perhaps know was
fairly thick on the ground in in this
area and I also want to thank Doug
Jeffery and president Larry Arne for
extending the invitation and I think
some of the things you're going to hear
me say about the about scandals in the
founding era may surprise you or not
but before I delve into the real subject
of this lecture I want to set the scene
for you because the United States in the
1790s was very different from the
country we know today it was small frail
it was under populated it was a far cry
from the muscular superpower that we all
take for granted
settlement extended only from the
Atlantic coast to the wilderness of
Tennessee Kentucky and Ohio Philadelphia
the largest city had a population of
just 45,000 people which is almost
precisely the size of Hillsdale County
today New York the nation's capital for
the first years of the decade had only a
population of 30,000 and that city where
much of what I'll be talking about took
place extended only a few blocks north
of Wall Street most of Manhattan Island
try to picture this was a bucolic
countryside of farms orchards craggy
hills and dirt roads and the sight of
our present capital washed
in DC which will figure prominently in
my talk was rolling farmland occupied by
a few plantations that dependent on
slave labor with native industry and its
infancy Americans imported from Europe
everything from shoe buckles and spurs
and paint and fishing hooks buttons
toothbrushes and not to mention luxury
items it took three days to travel the
hundred miles from Philadelphia to the
Future Sight of Washington on roads that
were so so afflicted with stumps and
ruts that it was customary for drivers
to call to their passengers to act as
ballast by first leaning from one side
and then to the other to keep the coach
from overturning and a crazy quilt of
state jurisdictions maddeningly
complicated travel for instance when
Thomas Jefferson journeyed from Richmond
to New York in 1790 to take up his
duties as Secretary of State he had to
juggle four different state currencies
those of Virginia Maryland Pennsylvania
and New York all at discounts to pay his
expenses along the way because of
stringent property qualifications which
varied from state to state only a very
small percentage of the country's 4
million inhabitants had any role in
political life just under 700,000 were
slaves who of course had no rights to
liberty or property at all
and Americans had only barely begun to
think of themselves as a single people
our present Confederacy is not very
unlike the monster of Nebuchadnezzar
which was composed of brass clay and
iron
it's neither completely national federal
nor sovereign complained William Tudor
who was a friend of Vice President John
Adams southerners distrusted New
Englanders New Englanders distrusted
just about everyone Southerners
distrusted Pennsylvanians one
Pennsylvania representative remarked
that he had less feeling for anything
going on in new
York then for the transactions in grand
Cairo
the New Yorkers and I are on an equal
footing mutual civility without a grain
of good liking between us so think of
this when you imagine we the the early
republic as as kind of a a hug fest with
everybody getting along wonderfully
together men such as James Madison
George Washington Alexander Hamilton
among the many of the less renowned
founders had great hope for the new
system of government what Patrick Henry
called this crazy machine Patrick Henry
by the way hated the new government he
hated the Constitution but reconciled
himself to it grudgingly but this new
system of government that had been
crafted by the Constitutional Convention
but there also worried that it simply
might not work and it and that it could
come crashing down at any time a great
deal remained unresolved would the
checks and balances really work who had
the authority to interpret the
Constitution with the northern states
help defend the southern against a slave
uprising would the south come to the aid
of the north in the event of a foreign
invasion
James Madison nervously remarked in 1789
we are in a wilderness without a single
footstep to guide us so it's against
this backdrop that the stories I'm going
to tell you unfolded so try to imagine
this the President of the United States
simultaneously holds the nation's
highest executive office and the
chairmanship of a private corporation
that's engaged in raising investment for
massive development project that would
increase the value of his own property
many times over now I'm talking of
course about George Washington into the
early months of his presidency he
continued to lead the Potomac Company
which had been organized for the
commercial development of the Potomac
River with a view to making it into the
country's
main thoroughfare into the westward into
the West Country to the interior of
North America its development would also
dramatically increased the value of
Washington's vast land holdings in
western Pennsylvania and present-day
West Virginia but in 1789 it's hardly
anyone batted an eye
not so much because Washington was
beyond reproach though he pretty much
was but because what we call conflict of
interest was rarely perceived as
politically scandalous in the early days
of the Republic Washington wasn't alone
most of the government's leading men
held potentially very lucrative
investments that would benefit from
legislation they actively and often
openly promoted so then just just what's
a scandal at least in 1790 is something
is scandal because the behavior involved
is inherently illegal immoral unethical
or unseemly by today's standards or by
our ancestors standards this brief look
at what scandalized our forebears of the
1790s will show us something about how
our notion of what constitutes a public
or a political scandal has changed and
why what shocks us today may have
shocked almost no one then and by the
same token why much of what scandalized
them means little to us now there's no
better place to begin than the masa
nations that surrounded the
establishment of the national capital or
as it was then called the federal city
many different sites more than 30 were
under consideration from Kingston New
York to Norfolk Virginia but the main
contenders were in New York City the
home of the federal government at the
time several sites in Pennsylvania and
on the Potomac regional advocates
lobbied ferociously for their favorite
locations among these the boldest
example was Pennsylvania senator Robert
Morris who bought up land at every
proposed site near Philadelphia and
battled hard to place the capital on
any one of them his fellow senator from
Pennsylvania William McClay the two
hated each other by the way
William McClay worked equally hard to
win the Capitol for a site on the
Susquehanna River where he and his
political allies owned land after a
sequence of horse trading backroom deals
so many of them that I I wouldn't dare
begin to recount them for you Congress
finally settled on the Potomac but where
on the Potomac Congress deputed George
Washington to pick the best spot it was
generally expected that he would select
a site far upriver where Maryland is
narrowest so that the federal district
might eventually encompass parts of
three states Pennsylvania Maryland and
Virginia
instead he insisted on the present site
most of which lay outside the zone
mandated by Congress and required
Congress to vote again to enlarge that
zone to accommodate him the site he
chose as we all know lies conveniently
across the river from his property at
Mount Vernon after Washington's death
John Adams tartly declared that the deal
raised the value of Washington's
properties a thousand percent the
president also raised the rents on his
lands in the area as soon as Congress
approved the site he then named three of
his friends all principals of the
Potomac Company as commissioners to
manage the development of the capital
now in today's terms Washington's
actions obviously represented a gross
conflict of interest but no one even
suggested censoring him nothing he did
was illegal at the time nor did any
congressional committees exist to
investigate it even if it had been in
this Washington was very much a man of
his times by the same token at least
dozens of members of Congress were
simultaneously speculating in the
radically discounted script that
Revolutionary War veterans had been
issued in lieu of pay knowing that it
would dramatically spike in value when
Alexander Hamilton
financial plan for redeeming the
national and state debts went into
effect deals of this sort made many of
them rich in short commercial
self-interest among public officials was
pretty much taken for granted but then
we come to the creation of the Federal
City itself in there's quite a different
story to be told the national government
appropriated no money to build the
Capitol the president's mansion or
anything else instead a fast-talking
young senate financier named samuel
Blodgett who had served as an aide to
washington during the war convinced the
president and the commissioners that he
could raise all the money that was
needed he offered to put together a
$500,000 loan from private investors
promising to deliver the money to the
commissioners and regular installments
the commissioners would in turn in
return pledged City Lots as security
Blodgett assured them that massive
investment would drive up the value of
the Lots by 40% essentially Blodgett
played Washington Jefferson and the
commissioners like a pitchman hustling a
crowd of hayseeds at at a country fair
meanwhile New York's embryonic and
unregulated financial market was in the
throes of what contemporaries called
Banco mania a hurricane of speculation
and government bonds that prompted the
overnight establishment of flimsily
financed and unstable banks this bubble
Alexander Hamilton later reported was in
fact artificial and violent such as no
discrete calculation of probabilities
could have supposed the master
manipulator at the eye of this hurricane
was William Duer Hamilton's former
assistant secretary of the Treasury who
exploited insider information gained
from his position in an attempt to
corner at the New York bond market
cornered by creditors he was reduced to
borrowing not just from banks and fellow
finance seers but from shopkeepers
widows
and even one of the city's better known
Madame's he failed in March 1792 Dewar's
collapse brought on the nation's first
Wall Street Crash bankrupting many of
the city's biggest money men including
James Wilson a Justice of the Supreme
Court who was imprisoned for debt as a
result of failed speculations and spent
the rest of his life running from
creditors Dewar himself was financially
ruined almost lynched and jailed in
debtors prison from which he never
emerged the cash reserves of the Bank of
the United States plummeted by 34
percent prompting the bank to call in a
quarter of its outstanding loans now bad
as this was it would have been a great
deal worse without the cook without
quick work by Alexander Hamilton who
acted to stabilize the securities market
and staved off a full-scale recession
interest rates soared to a ruinous 1% a
day Hamilton wrote his time there must
be a line of separation between honest
men and knaves between respectable
stockholders and dealers in the funds
and more unprincipled gamblers now
Americans would still be saying much the
same thing two centuries later meanwhile
back on the Potomac the money upon which
Samuel Blodgett you remember him
Samuel Blodgett along with the president
the commissioners in Congress had pinned
their hopes upon evaporated into thin
air scarcely anyone was interested in
buying land in the federal district and
of those who did many refused to pay the
only real winner was Blodgett himself
who acquired at a secretly discounted
price the most valuable piece of real
estate on offer
since land sale seemed unpromising
Blodgett proposed another scheme raising
money through a lottery with three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
prizes including a non-existent hotel
it's true I kid you not once again
pelagic Blodgett succeeded in gulling
the commissioners as well as Washington
and Jefferson when this two failed to
generate any income
the commissioners finally begged
Blodgett to stop the business as soon as
possible by 1793
construction of the government buildings
had almost completely stalled the
federal city looked set to become a
spectacular national failure with
serious consequences for the frail young
Republic if the buildings were not
completed at the end of the ten-year
deadline set by Congress that's November
1800 the Capitol would remain very
likely permanently in Philadelphia at
this dire moment three new financed ears
with impeccable credentials rode to the
rescue James Greenleaf of Boston who had
made a fortune in land speculation John
Nicholson Pennsylvania's respected
Comptroller General and US Senator
Robert Morris who having failed to win
the Capitol for Pennsylvania now staked
his fortune and reputation on cornering
the real estate in the federal district
they bought out Blodgett and promised to
succeed where he had failed the economic
historian Am Sikorsky writing in the
1930s would call them the greatest
land-grabbing triumvirate that ever
operated in America the partners
contracted with the commissioners to buy
thousands of Lots in the federal city
for over a million dollars they
committed themselves to erect a house
and every third locked into paying the
commissioners annual installments over
the next seven years until the project
was completed in all they controlled 42
percent of the available real estate in
the district to pay for it they would
float a 1.2 million dollar loan a
stupendous sum at the time from lenders
in Europe so from here on the capital's
fate essentially became the prisoner of
a speculative scheme so gargantuan and
tangled that it still defies attempts to
fully unravel it
essentially the three partners created a
pyramid scheme its collapse literally
shook the capital to its already shaky
foundations first because of political
instability in Europe the partners were
unable to raise more than a fraction of
the loans they sought second the largest
portion of their collateral lay in 2.3
million acres of unsurveyed and
unsalable land in Georgia mired in
clouded claims burdened with unpaid
taxes occupied by very combative
squatters and already encumbered for
debt in short no one wanted it and they
couldn't get rid of it within a few
years the trio's wealth disappeared into
financial quicksand by now the partners
owed the commissioners tens of thousands
of dollars that they couldn't pay along
with a contractual obligation to build
hundreds of houses that they couldn't
afford to build for the next two years
they were they were like aerialists
tightrope walkers seemingly suspended in
the air with their legs churning
spinning over the heads of their
audience of creditors public officials
and prospective investors struggling to
pull off one new financial trick that
would keep them solvent instead they
came down in a heap broke plagued by
lawsuits Morris became a virtual
prisoner in his Philadelphia home
Nicholson was reduced to looting a
Presbyterian widows fund of which he was
a trustee and attempting to Lisa hotel
in the federal city for a brothel in
1798 their luck ran out both Nicholson
and Morris wound up in debtors prison in
Philadelphia
virtually penniless and their
reputations and ruins Morris remained
there three and a half years he came out
a broken man and died five years later
near oblivion virtually erased from the
pantheon of the nation's founders
Nicholson died in prison leaving a wife
eight children and 12 million dollars in
debt
Greenleaf the slickest of the three
spent less than a year in jail the
collapse of the speculative bubble
brought land sales and construction in
the federal city almost to a halt
thousands of the best land best Lots
were encumbered by liens and litigation
would be investors regarded the places
of failure in the end grudging
appropriations by Congress in the state
of Maryland provided enough money for
the government buildings to be completed
by the 1800 deadline but just barely
you could still smell the paint inside
the walls of the Capitol building as
Congress arrived it would be generations
before Washington grew into anything
like the Grand National Capitol that the
founders had imagined so I asked what
was the difference between George
Washington's transparent conflicts of
interest and Robert Morris's
speculations now a cynic might say
merely that one man's scheme succeeded
and the others failed and that winners
don't have to justify themselves of
course gratitude to Washington as the
Paramount hero of the Revolutionary War
meant that in fact he could do almost no
wrong in the public eye at least in the
early days of his presidency even John
Adams regarded his transgressions if
that's what they were as unseemly rather
than illicit
even Mars and Nicholson like doer before
them were not prosecuted for fraud or
insider trading
they were jailed for indebtedness now
honor is it word rarely heard in public
life in our own day but it was a quality
that men of the 18th century rated among
the most sterling and essential of human
virtues a man's honor could be breached
or enhanced in many ways but one of the
surest ways to lose it to become
dishonored was to fall into debt which
entailed the betrayal of one's creditors
and we should bear in mind that many
innocent people were ruined financially
as a result of these speculators schemes
I'll mention again that did in 1796
James Wilson remember the Supreme Court
was twice imprisoned for death
up to now I've been talking only about
financial misbehavior but what about the
more personal kinds of scandal misdeeds
of the boudoir so to speak or in plain
language sex scandals the looms so large
on our own time entangling so many
politicians in the early national era
Americans sometimes seemed quite
puritanical but not always in
predictable ways in 1789 the French
ambassador scandalized New York society
by living openly with a woman who is not
his wife but the living arrangements of
the apparently homosexual Peter L'Enfant
the desire the designer of Washington DC
cause no recorded comment at all I
suspect that in many such cases that
tacit Don't Ask Don't Tell policy was
practiced and then there was Alexander
Hamilton in 1791 23 year old Maria
Reynolds approached Treasury Secretary
Hamilton then 34 years old and married
and asked him for help and money saying
that her husband James Reynolds a minor
government of government official and
speculator had abandoned her and that
she was in desperate straits Hamilton
went to her boarding house where he
later wrote it was quickly apparent that
other than pecuniary consolation would
be acceptable the clandestine affair
that ensued went on for at least a year
this arrangement quickly evolved into a
con on the part of the Reynolds's James
Reynolds was aware of the affair
possibly from the start and encouraged
it in order to blackmail Hamilton
Reynolds wrote to him in January 1792 I
have not the least objection to your
calling as a friend to both of us
I rely on your befriending me if there
should be anything to offer that would
be to my advantage in all Reynolds
extorted at least 1,300 dollars from
Hamilton later in 17
to Reynolds who's jailed on fraud
charges stemming from an attempt to
misuse funds intended for Revolutionary
War veterans he then used knowledge of
his wife's affair in an effort to
extricate himself from prison he
revealed the affair to Senator James
Monroe and others in Congress who
accused Hamilton of corruption believing
that he must have paid off Reynolds with
money from the Treasury this was not in
fact the case Hamilton had paid the
blackmail with his own money
his accusers accepted his denial and the
business was hushed up however Monroe
sent incriminating copies of the letters
between Reynolds and Hamilton to his
close ally and Hamilton's arch enemy
Thomas Jefferson five years later in
1797 James Callender
at that time a propagandist for
Jefferson made the made the affair
public in a pamphlet Hamilton angrily
confronted Monroe for betraying him
words were exchanged each called the
other a scoundrel and a liar a duel
between the two was only narrowly
averted through the efforts of none
other than Aaron Burr though of course
would himself kill Hamilton and a duel
in 1804 can't make it up by this time
the reynolds affair was public knowledge
a major embarrassment to Hamilton and
one of several factors that denied him
any further role in public office he
published a 95 page pamphlet in his
defense in which he admitted to the
affair in great detail apologized for it
and once again denied that he had done
anything corrupt in his role as Treasury
secretary although Hamilton remained
high in the esteem of George Washington
his reputation was permanently tarnished
less however for his sexual
improprieties than for succumbing to
bribery and for his concealment of it
which fed into a wide perception among
Jeffersonian Democrats and some of his
fellow Federalists that Hamilton was a
man who just couldn't be trusted
the propagandist James Callender was
also a pivotal figure in what today is
doubtless the most famous scandal of the
era after two centuries of denial by
Thomas Jefferson's white descendants
virtually all historians now accept that
he kept an enslaved negro concubine with
whom he had sexual relations for decades
and produced several children salacious
allusions to dusky Sally were part and
parcel of what might be termed America's
first golden age of scandal mongering
they were a coda to the fiercely
contested election of 1800 which was one
of the dirtiest in American history
right up to our own time and I think a
case could be made that it was by far
the dirtiest frankly that election
represented the first handover of power
from one hostile political party to
another from Federalists to Democratic
Republicans an unprecedented experience
that encouraged candidates to demonize
the opposition as satanic threats rather
than to regard them as worthy and
principled competitors sound familiar if
you think that today's press by the way
is too partisan you should read the
newspapers of the 1800 the aurora for
example when there was no such thing as
fair and balanced coverage of anything
Jefferson's Republicans Democrat
Republicans formally accused Federalists
Adams of insanity senility plotting to
establish a monarchy hatred of the
people collusion with Britain against
American interests and of having a
hideous hermaphroditical character
you know take that the Federalists
accused Jefferson of having cheated his
law clients showing cowardice in the
face of the enemy during the Revolution
atheism and being head of the French
party in America one partisan journalist
predicted that if Jefferson were to be
elected licentiousness and immorality
would meet with the most public
approbation every restraint would soon
be thrown off and men would soon bring
themselves to be infamous debo Shay's
assassins cheats thieves liars
hateful and hating one another a curse
upon the earth 1800
so the accusation against Jefferson of
miscegenation was thus but once girl is
charged among many there had been rumors
for some time that Jefferson was
carrying on a liaison with an enslaved
woman then in 1802 the hints became
explicit when the pamphleteer James
Callender now a renegade former
supporter of Jefferson wrote in the
richmond recorder it is well known that
the man who matt delighteth the people
to honor keeps and for many years past
has kept as his concubine one of his own
slaves her name is Sally
that's boldface all caps calendar
asserted that had this come out during
the presidential campaign the
establishment of this single fact would
have rendered his election impossible
calendar clearly was was implying that
this this fact was sufficiently
scandalous in rather the terms in which
we use that word to prevent Jefferson
from having been elected but in short
party loyalties then to defined the
fault lines of outrage
much as Richard Goodwin this afternoon
to suggested they do today the outcome
had had this fact been had calendar
written his article before the election
the outcome is unknowable today but it's
clear that in the early republic many
perhaps most americans were on the whole
fairly tolerant of the vagaries of human
nature public men generally were seen as
fallible whether in the pursuit of
either speculative riches or of dusky
maidens and relationships that
transgress the nominal ballot boundaries
of polite society as a net gordon-reed
has pointed out in a masterful
examination of that Hemings Jefferson
relationship their liaison was
apparently not all that unusual for the
time and place scandal as the rest of
this conference will will make clear as
a history of its own it evolves and it
changes today there's nothing scandalous
about indebtedness virtually all
Americans now live with a degree of debt
that would mortify our
eighteenth-century ancestors and while
personal bankruptcy may be embarrassing
it rarely causes a major scandal
moreover in the early republic what was
a scandal in one part of the country may
not have been in another the revelation
of Jefferson's a relationship with Sally
Hemings
probably shocked straight-laced
Federalist New Englanders for example
more than a did men in the slave states
where such relationships who were all
too common if not often spoken of in
polite society and few but few Americans
today would consider a biracial
relationship as scandalous on the other
hand in this era of the me2 movement
Jefferson's reputation would doubtless
be destroyed in the press and public
opinion for what would be deemed
prolonged sexual abuse within a power
relationship so if there's a lesson to
be drawn from this this brief tour of
the 1790
it's that scandal at least historically
speaking is often in the eye of the
beholder is a scandal really a scandal
if no one takes notice such as George
Washington self-dealing over the site of
the nation's capital today it would
surely be cause for impeachment while
the indebtedness of Robert Morris or
William Duer would it would hardly
condemn them to prison
on the other hand doers insider-trading
certainly would send him to the clink
today though it was not a crime in 1792
so it should be said the none of these
scandals or dare I say non scandals
many cases threaten the survival of the
government which at the start of the
decade had seemed so very fragile partly
that was because popular opinion
mattered far less than it does today
because relatively so few people could
vote it was also because by and large
Americans trusted their leaders flawed
and humans are they revealed themselves
to be they also trusted their new
institutions to survive and that if
those institutions broke then they would
fix them as they saw fit as
representative George Thatcher of
Massachusetts put it in 1792 politics
are the meat and drink of the people in
a free government and if it does not
suit us faith we will correct the cook
and I personally find that a remark that
that that we should all know and might
well remember because he's talking about
what democracy does best which is fix
itself and to conclude I'll say well we
ought to pause before judging the
behavior of our forebears by today's
values usually a mistake we have every
reason to be grateful to the subsequent
generations of Jurists crusading
journalists and ordinary citizens for
insisting on
standards of probity and decency that
few Americans in the 1790s could dream
of thank you
[Applause]